we're working on a movie that's got a
budget of a hundred mil
right it was sword fishing swordfish so
travolta
halle berry hugh jackman and and don
uh i was sort of the the fifth wheel but
uh i came in as a day player right to do
just a couple scenes with don and then
don was like yo
i need a partner for this movie and then
they looked at me said all right
that's it how about that he's your
partner for this movie
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
with me george lopez let's do the show
i'm gonna go to that directly right here
my kid phelps
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere
what's his name george lopez george
lopez
oh my god omg omg bye
oh my god hi
have you ever met guild before i've
never met gil yeah just until writing
well
i've seen him on tv what was he doing on
tv when he was
chris henson to catch a predator yeah
they did brian kitchen
hey is that legal a sting like that
that show yeah it wasn't wasn't cops
running it
it was him running it was the show
running it so
if the cops would have been running it
that still would have been legal
there's no entrapment there i mean
they're doing it here hey this guy's out
there breaking
violating the law by doing that so
they're following up on a crime no it's
we have people today law enforcement
agents today have people that are doing
that
computer crimes just following them well
i mean do you agree that angelo
pagan do you agree that everything that
you have on your computer
is seen by someone or is tracked by
someone
absolutely a lot of times people cover
their
their camera with a little that's with
the tape because they can see you
you know putting together a shower
with
my wife and i sometimes we're like
papers they're like oh they got notch
i think they can hear you you just pass
they tell you to turn
i got a feeling when they come to my
house and start to watch and listen
they turn their computers off they don't
want to see it they'll be like no
pack it in now you know at least crying
you know we
we have people come to the house and
sweep the place just to make sure that
you do not beat that without being you
know
how often but he has a situation you
already have a situation but but
those spy stores and all that stuff or
software that people put on
on someone's computer do wives do that
to husbands or husbands
i'm not smart enough to stay up on you
listen if you don't want to answer just
say you don't want to answer
my life you might have to ask his wife
that one i know
he's like she probably got he's a
world-class detective
he does that [ __ ] to throw you up like
listen man i don't know what it is
like okay how about this how about you
go to a restaurant or
you're in the parking lot and a guy is
arguing with his wife
and your wife says go in there and and
tell that guy to leave her alone
what is it what's a civilian to do call
it cops or call management stay out of
it but don't go in there right yeah just
leave it alone you know be a good
witness that's all you can do okay
today in because of civil liabilities
and all the civil legality that's going
on
you don't get unless it gets physical
you know you you
is that a good question angela that's a
great question especially
i own a restaurant right okay so so we
have tell everybody what restaurant it
is
vivian's cafe chain there there's so
many that
there's a chain of one of the chain of
one the three v's
it's checked out of the afternoon it's
the only restaurant in l.a
in the sacramento valley that opened at
six in the morning close at 7
15 a.m
you're gonna mess up my hours people are
gonna show up at seven i'm not gonna be
open
okay so let's answer that question i got
another one vivian's
on ventura and vineland that's a great
place so
sometimes also you don't think marijuana
makes you lazy i've been i've been going
over there for five months and some
basketball players that are retired
he said hey they're opening a marijuana
store next door looks the [ __ ] same
for the last five bucks
we were going to fix that wall but then
we got high
yeah i still believe it makes you lazy
okay so go so go ahead so you have a
restaurant
so you know sometimes the homeless will
come and sit
and like just like build that whole
living room right in front of my
property right and i'm ah so that i call
the cops and like yeah well you can't
touch them
because okay i'm not gonna put my hands
on anyone
but out comes the manger because it's
spring cleaning time
and that's the only way i can do it so i
hold the whole place down
well right here what rights do they have
i i'm not familiar
all this stuff started once once i left
before
that's the problem together
uh before you couldn't it was against a
lot of block sidewalk now people are
living on the sidewalk they're blocking
parking lanes and everything else
and the court system has said you can't
move them unless you find an alternate
place for them to live
so they're between a rock and a hard
spot and you can't and
they're i feel sorry for them because
some of them
are homeless veterans with ptsd
some of them are just people that don't
have nothing that are lazy
they're still humans and they're taking
advantage of the system they're using it
for dope sales and using dope other
people are nuts out there
and but i don't know what the answer but
also you know yesterday we were in here
and uh those guys were saying that they
carry pieces now like homeless people
they get they have
weapons and they have guns in their
tents so if you go in there and you're
trying to be like hey man you got to
move your
house outside of my restaurant and
they'll fire on you yeah move this
yeah don't [ __ ] so you have to be
careful well that's good to know because
they'll they'll fire
i'm changing my plans of the for tonight
but i was going to be
all but they do not now it's a bigger
problem like you know i would just only
say los angeles you lived in new york
it's a bigger problem now you know san
francisco
and san francisco has always been a big
problem but but what's the answer to the
to the homelessness in this country
move them you know let them find them
finding places to move
uh i'm affirmable i i feel sorry for
them my heart goes out
how many people would love to live and
been on venice beach but they can't
afford it
but yet they can set up camp and they
can do whatever they want
and what about our soldiers that are in
afghanistan and in iraq
that are living in all that heat with
all the packing and they live in tents
in the summer
while we have plenty of land out here
that we can certainly build them
their own community if they want to live
but they don't want it so i don't know
what the answer isn't part of it
and a lot of them are now mentally
challenged you know they have problems
mentally so it's a tough issue one that
i'm glad
i'm not asked to answer you know it's
it's
it's definitely my my question is where
are the
families of these people because i know
that
we got a couple of locals in our family
but you know we try to
we try to help them out oh wait a minute
what's going on
homeless and we drink here
your wife will be like
a sidewalk in front of the restaurant
um that's the george lopez mexico
style logo
twenty percent meows all right so only
20.
just a flavor but but uh yeah so so it's
a bigger issue
and even now they have uh second stories
on there and they have gardens
yeah they do they do it in like kawanga
over the 101 he's got an elevator in the
palace going on yeah yeah
he's got a two-story place you know it's
it's incredible
so a lot of times people live paycheck
to paycheck which is
very very very difficult and um
or if they're married and they picture
the pet check and they get separated
then the wife ends up on the street
it's a and i don't think they have
those like the is it midnight mission i
don't know if that's
it's still there it's still there i'll
tell you what
it was just within the last two years i
was working i was
working temporarily for uh department of
children and family services
i was working in internal affairs yeah
just for a while they asked me if i'd do
it help them out for
and right outside how many times did you
cry every day because i know you're all
right
i didn't cry these people you didn't cry
no no no come on
these are just people that i wasn't
dealing with the victims
i was dealing with people within the
company that were messing up okay if you
were dealing with the victims you'd be
crying all the time
he's got a big heart i couldn't i
couldn't deal with the kids on a steady
diet
i had a big waist but i had
there's a guy that lived across the
street you know he had his
tent set up and he was trees to hold it
up and
keep the rain out and and that guy
i'm not kidding you walk to the corner
he's standing at the corner you know
what's he doing over here and here comes
uh
ups made a delivery to him took a packet
from up
on the corner oh my god
so what do you do you sit there what are
you gonna do
i don't know i i didn't have the answer
but they're also aggressive so i would
say for people to be careful because
you know you they might be a nuisance to
you but they're the ones on the street
yeah
and they give them well when i come out
with the hoes and i do it kommucha be
careful
yeah because what nationalities are does
it matter
be careful yeah
in particular were of the anglo uh
persuasion
but uh yes
and you know white homeless people
bubble off
most of them are white homeless what are
you talking about you don't see a lot of
mexican puerto rican homeless out there
because we take care of our own out
there i used to when i'd leave
my office was near a little let's say uh
sixth in vermont you know that area
that's where the offices were i'd go
down
sixth street to go home and you go down
the skid row area
both parking lanes were taken with
people living on the streets and on the
sidewalk
and people somebody walking around naked
picking flies and birds out of the sky
and nobody cares it's like that's normal
around here
you know it's different people get in
the way and i'm sitting here one day i'm
i'm going by and some guy
some lady has got a shopping cart and
looks like she's gonna ram a car
and i and i have a decent vehicle and
i'm saying now what am i going to do you
know
yeah do i hit the lady if she comes up
to my car in front of it do i hit her do
i stop let her wreck my car
you know she comes up with a couple of
people do i you know i was packing
and if they're going to attack me what
do i do
and you just wait
i stop my vehicle wait for some other
car to come by then i punched it
well she was distracted i got through
and
no law enforcement around and these
people aren't doing anything because
that's everyday activity out there
the everyday activity do you well you
don't have to answer this i think you
already did
do you carry 100 of the time not 100
about 90
of the time um
and it's hard to get a license to carry
as a civilian right
it's it was almost impossible locally
before but now it's a little easier
it is a little let me ask you how about
this how about this if you hit a
homeless person in the middle of the
night let's say you're coming back from
the club or
from would you pull over should a person
pull over or you figure because they're
homeless like
oh no i'd pull over that's a hit and run
i don't know do you mean you may hit
them with the car
yeah yeah that's that's true yeah i'm
not gonna go to jail for anybody
because like if they're dead what are
you stopping for really
i'm only kidding no but if you know if
they
you have to stop okay i have to stop you
have to stop
okay yeah made a good point not going to
jail for anyone even if it's a weird
situation but i think that
in these in this climate there's fear
in everybody there's fear like you know
you have kids
you have a daughter your young man that
that when they go out um how would you
say that they don't get
is do people still carjack i i think
they yeah yeah oh yeah kidding yeah
i think you have to pick i think this is
this isn't just for like
l.a i think this is just as a concerned
parent that you would
you would almost have your child not go
out from like
eight to midnight on a week like the the
less
the the more you can get done during the
day yeah and the less you're out at
night
i think you're i don't even like my 22
year old grandson
who works out four days a week he built
like a
like a brick house good i don't even
like him going out on the street he
drives a nice car
and they'll jack him they'll beat him
just because they're
celos you know they're jealous uh
problem
he's not a banger doesn't do any never
been in trouble he's a good kid
i don't know that he's street smart he's
been so good i don't know that he's
street smart enough
to stay out of the wrong areas or
whatever
it's uh well you could always do what i
do i put a track well
for him i'm not sure but i put a tracker
on my daughter's car oh yeah of course
and when i see where she's at in certain
areas i jump in the car
and next thing you know i'm there and
she's like dad how interesting that we
show up in the same places together okay
so if you haven't figured it out yeah
dog if you lose a dog and that dog
ends up one time there was a jack
russell terrier that had a party at my
house
and jack russell terriers are they take
off right this [ __ ] jack russell
chair was a monrovia
in 25 minutes they found him that
[ __ ] was in monrovia
and they just took up went all the way
up olive got on a 210
got off on verdugo
but they ship them and they find the
owner but kids they don't chip
are you against shipping kids
like they catch a dog they take the
thing they put it on them they own her
with a number
but a little kid that gets lost
or taken you have to control your own
fears you know i i can't
do that they have privacy rights they
have this i'm not going to follow them
all the way
and you know my wife you know she she's
always in fear
however you can't let fear dictate your
life either
[ __ ] it's crazy the dark web
see that dark web i'm bidding on some
little chinita
so yeah yeah so all right so angel so
angelo
is uh is puerto rican born
in the islands no i was actually born
you are actually in the island of the
bronx
and then i grew up in the island of
manhattan which
it's really an island but the island of
manhattan um
very different than when we we brought
up where did you grow up and what part
of the bronx there's a lot of talent
that
there's a lot of talent in the bronx
who's come out of the bronx
who's come out of the bronx jennifer oh
yeah a lot of actors jimmy smith
jimmy smits and you know what's
funny is those two actually owned the
first conga room
right there on on wilshire first coming
room on wilshire was a beautiful place
yeah yeah beautiful they screwed up the
second one but anyway but yeah jimmy
smits and jennifer they were they both
uh were owners there
oh no you've been in new york you've
been in new york i've been to new york
one time on a case i loved it
i just thought it was all all i could do
was laugh you could walk
every other word out of their mouth was
[ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] them you know and
and i just
i'm laughing at it oh we can say [ __ ] on
this yeah so
as my cop my cop driver you know he's
driving me around
and he sees me live he said what are you
laughing about i said i just love your
accent i love that every other word out
of your mouth as [ __ ]
he says you know he said let me tell you
[ __ ] something right now
he says love it people not from new york
he says they the late
they either love us or they [ __ ] hate
us what they don't [ __ ] know is we
hate the [ __ ] out of each other
yeah right that's true that what what
case was it that drove that one to don't
have to say
what it was murder case yeah yeah yeah
that's the only thing i'd go on it was a
murder case it was out of a
local uh gambling gambling parlor over
here
and led us to new york and new york cops
just do different
you know back then this is probably back
in the
late 80s early 90s and they do things
differently over there you know it was
just
it was incredible that pre or post son
of sam
uh that was post yeah yeah
these guys were just something else you
know they they did things their own way
and they've gotten
i said if we if we tried that back in
l.a you know we'd be fired we'd be in
jail
these guys didn't care great bunch of
guys to work with
uh i played a song new york's finest i
played a softball tournament in vegas
and i was pitching slow pitch he only
goes seven innings
and it's a tie score bases are loaded
two outs i'm on the mount i'm pitching
against new york
and then guys from new york they start
giving me the wave from inside their
dugout
and i'm just up to i'm i'm laughing i'm
laughing up on the mountain you can hear
him say
look at this crazy [ __ ] he says
the winning runs on [ __ ] base and
he's out there [ __ ] laughing
so they won the game they beat me they
came in and
after the game they said hey why don't
you go with us we're going to go have
some fun now and i told the guys i was
with
i'm see you later i'm going with the
guys i love them
and they came out here a couple of times
when i was doing ring announcing uh
boxers from new york would come out and
fight the guys from lapd
and the sheriff's deputies were doing
ring announcements well i've done it at
the olympic auditorium i've done it
for the poli for the police olympics not
the big olympic police olympics
uh done a few pro fights but i i loved
it the guys from new york were
always a blast to be around i i love
them
let me ask you a question in terms of
everything that's happening with the
with the police
right of course every time somebody does
something bad
the media is all over it how are you
guys dealing with that internally with
the
you know with the bad cops and the good
cops not really
doing anything in terms of protecting
people from the bad cops
let me let me say this the
the guys that are working now my heart
goes out to them they've got a job to do
and they're just going to do it to their
the best they can they understand
they're under pressure but they're going
to get the job done
there are bad cops out there and the bad
cops make it bad on
everybody including those of us that are
retired i haven't lost faith in them
those guys are still going
they're busting their asses out there to
try to do things right and you're not
going to stop them from
saving your life and we talked about it
once on the show a couple of episodes
ago where
the father that just lost his son was
one of the biggest advocates against the
against law enforcement he wants some
hell to answer cut their funds
and now his son got murdered and now the
same people that he wanted to help
defund and he was an activist against
he wants them to solve his son's murder
yeah and
and he says yes i was an activist
and i still want cops to be brought to
justice if they mess up
well good cops want bad cops brought to
justice
he said but i also want justice for my
son
and as he should receive it he should
get it not because he's an activist not
because
anything just because he's a resident of
the city of los angeles in this case and
everybody
deserves justice nobody has a right to
take anybody else's life but also
but also i don't think the police
departments
in los angeles or even across the
country want to admit
how under police they are certainly how
they need thousands more officers and
how nobody wants to be a police officer
why would you
my grandson was going he had filed he
had applied he was going to be a police
officer he says he wanted
his dad's a cop but more than that he
said i want to be like you
papa me just i want to be like you and
he applied he and i said you do it you
do it all on your own i'm not
you know no help so he did it he applied
everything's going good and i asked him
one day you know what happened son
and he just didn't
want to talk about it at first his mom
told me that he had
had to change her heart talked it over
with his dad just the way things were
going law enforcement he
it changed his mind and he was a good
kid and
he didn't want to tell me because he
thought that i'd be disappointed and i
pulled i said no son you know i'm happy
that you made the decision
this job isn't for everybody and i'm
glad you recognize it now
because it would only come out later on
somebody might have been hurt well i
mean if you have
if you're hesitant about anything that
you're doing especially something that's
life and death every
every situation you should be 100
in because it it's a tough
it's a tough because it's it's your own
life is on sure patrol
and all of those do you think that those
guys that you know a lot of people now
have uh
you know you pay like personal security
like those guys that drive around the
middle of the night
uh i don't want to say a name but you
know the security that you pay for
three times around the house at night or
oh okay
do you think it's worth it yeah i don't
know i'm not
it's a set of eyes in the middle of the
night yeah i'm not wealthy enough to
afford
something like that but even if i could
i don't think i'd have you know once
again
i don't think i can live in fear my
house has been broken into before
and all i said was okay next time they
come i'm gonna put signs up around my
house hey okay
this stuff is over here this stuff is
over here don't make a mess of the rest
of the house
you know uh recently while doing a live
uh zoom with channel 11.
uh somebody the cops came they were
chasing somebody the guy tried to come
over my fence he had a tire iron in his
hand
and his partner went one way he came
here all of a sudden he saw that my son
was sitting right there
he got scared he ran off so i've been in
the same house for 40
47 48 years now it's the first time
something like that's happened yeah
so i'm not gonna move i'm not gonna hire
security to be out there protecting my
house or anything
it is what it is when it's your time
it's your time you know i i'm not a
i'm not a pessimist i'm not an optimist
i'm just a realist you know but also
people shouldn't leave things in their
car you got a lot of homes yeah when
they walk by
and you leave your computer in the car
or you leave your jacket in the car
that's going to be broken into you leave
nothing seen out in the open
make sure your doors are locked the only
thing that they can't protect against
right now and the big thing around
at least here in l.a county is catalytic
converters
people are stealing three minutes get in
there
and they're gone catalytic converters
it's got to do with engines or something
what about yeah it's a thing underneath
it's part of the exhaust system and what
do they do with them they go and sell
them they're about math
they're they're about uh fifteen to
twenty five hundred dollars a piece
to sell because there's like a metal
that breaks down constantly that's why
no no it
looks like a muffler the old the old
version of about
catalytic converters what they do um but
it's got there's got to be a huge market
we cut down on the missions there you go
yeah there's like a palladium i think
i need one for my cooler at night
housekeeper comes in mr lopez
the hybrid i'm glad i got a dog now you
know the dog in there dog farts terrible
yeah so now i'm in on him yeah so now
all i do is milo
get over there but but it does
you you know if you hear them barking
you know it's something yeah
like like um except for my dog you know
we picked him up
we found him he found us he's ours now
he doesn't bark
he doesn't matter the only time he
barked the guy that came with the
crowbar
it was like he was protecting us he
barked a little bit see he knows but he
knows
yeah he knew he was he knows now he's
there to protect
so in the area that i live in i hear a
lot of gunshots at
at night shotgun blast man and woman got
shot a couple weeks ago
shotgun blast banned and it makes a
sound after i didn't realize
if it when it shoots boom it makes a
sound after like
like a like a residue three times well
if it's a shotgun it's probably all over
the scan or the scattering yeah
scattering
and uh it makes me want to shoot a gun
in the air but i shouldn't
well let me let me tell you don't do it
straight up baba because i don't want it
to come down no i know man like that
but i've handled this i've handled desk
work somebody has shot
and come down and hit somebody they
think that the bullet's going to stay up
in the air
it's got to come down so be careful
they're going pretty fast too no no i
know
it comes down faster people think you're
shooting your gun in the air don't think
around my head be careful
those things go off around my house my
wife says was that a gunshot would i
said i don't know
it's either firecrackers fireworks or
it's a gun can it go through your roof
how no no okay it'll stop i said so if
you're that concerned about it baby i'm
gonna go back to sleep go out and go on
the front yard look around
somebody pulls a 22 on you should you be
afraid of your life oh yeah
okay yeah what about because it always
depends on what it hits
sure right that's right because then it
goes 22 ain't going to go through
22 cause a lot of damage because because
of such a small caliber small boat
bounces around on the inside wreaks
havoc on the inside
these other larger calibers the bigger
hole
bigger damage but it doesn't bounce
around and just goes through you
unless they're using and if it doesn't
hit any organs and it goes right through
yeah
right through good twenty threes are
dangerous i can't carry a weapon on you
without a permit in the car right
especially if it's loaded yeah uh
how many years am i gonna do in jail
when they find me i mean i mean
a person i mean my friend happens yeah
he
you know you advise people
somebody once told me i'd rather go see
you in jail than go to your funeral
yeah i think i think people you know i
think people are trying to
you know in a sense take the law into
their own hands sometimes when they go
and confront people
and they get yeah you can't either they
get knocked out or they get
shot or you see neighbor disputes if you
have a dispute with your neighbor
what do you do like you know there's
that neighbor that video where the guy
shot the wife and he shot the neighbor
went back and he shot
and killed them both and then went and
just sat on the pennsylvania right just
like walked right across the street and
went on the stoop
i think he shot himself yeah you just
all you do is eat crow
you forget that you're a macho man it's
your neighbor
there's a problem go back inside your
house leave them outside if you have a
bad neighbor what you yeah what should
you do if you have a neighbor that you
don't like
stay away from you should absolutely
chronicle though everything
exactly so that this way at least you
have some kind of a case that's why i
have video cameras around i do have
a lot of video uh around a lot of
cameras matter of fact we got the guy
with the tire iron
nice shot of that man so get a ring
camera and get it or
whatever camera to uh to see what's
going on exactly
you know there was a robbery up where i
live and then the police officer knocked
it it didn't have a uniform like it's an
investigator guy with the thing
and he said do you have your ring
footage from you know
mid-december and we did and they saw the
car
go by he was going on all the houses
that had cameras
and he saw that car go by sure and pull
that
uh i mean nowadays i don't think they
see me
that's crazy it's crazy that people
think that they're actually going to get
away with stuff just
and nobody cares and and with the
current
situation we're in here in l.a county
nothing's happening to them
i got burglary detectives telling me
burglary's a felony the suspects know
they get popped for a burglary says i
got guys copping out as soon as they
come out they say okay you got my ticket
ready
because they know they're going to get
sighted out you know you saw that guy in
san francisco going there on the bike
and he was pulling [ __ ] into a bat sure
and the and he you see that footage no i
didn't see the guy was in there
in a store and just started putting [ __ ]
into a bag oh that's right
it's just they let him leave you can't
you can't stop him right
that's right well you can but once again
civil liability's on the owner
uh my friend and i won't mention his
the the restaurant because i don't want
people to go down and start doing this
but the one i talked to about outside
where you know the parents you know when
you
when you sing he says he's got at least
two a night
they're going there order food eat then
just get up and walk away
yeah and you can't stop a man well you
you can
but then you risk the civil liability if
somebody gets hurt while you're trying
to detain them
then you know they're going to turn
around and sue the business and that's
money and
so what do you do it's uh
it's tough it's a tough world hmm
i don't have answers for these well the
cops should just kneecap you man lay you
out
and uh well not you know not not all of
them but but
they let you know that they they weren't
uh you won't [ __ ] that's right
you know and they're and they're just
cops are
everybody's trying to prevent civil
liability when do you call 9-1-1
because a lot of times they don't
whenever they're not going to show up
whenever it's in your mind an emergency
an emergency that's going to be life
death
or medical emergency of some form not
because somebody's not paying for you if
they're about to fight because it
dial 9-1-1 if there's a fight going on
or they're
fighting with your you know arguing with
your people down 9-1-1
you know that's an emergency could
because it could escalate
the fact that somebody just stole a
hundred dollars worth of food or a
hundred dollars worth of product you
know in a store
that's not an emergency it's there it's
gone
you know and it takes i believe the the
magic number now with 950
before it becomes a felony and uh
you know there's it's it's an ugly what
about road rage
don't get out of the car don't get out
of the car be a good witness
don't yeah you said that twice what is a
good witness like what makes a good good
witness somebody somebody will take the
time instead of yelling back you know
[ __ ] you
throw it on you take a license plate
number down if you have a
if you have a camera see him take it
remember as much as you can about and
then when the cops come come forward say
okay this is what i got
be good because people get killed in
road rage stuff and it's just by the
spur of the
emotions and people get shot that little
kid got shot i re it
and road rage is now the big thing but i
can remember when i was still working
patrol
uh going through the city of montebello
beverly boulevard some young kid
in a souped up name young
kid a little mexican kid driving a
candy apple red corvair
had it fixed up he pulls out of this
driveway right i had to slam on my
brakes went into a four-wheel lock skid
and he did it and he stopped and he
looked at me
and i just shook my head that's all i
did nothing more and i'm about two miles
from my station i'm going to patrol i'm
going to work
i just shook my head like that he made
his he made it out the street because he
was turning left in front of me he was
going out
he made a u-turn and started coming
after me he had two guys in the car with
him
and started coming after me and tried
running me off the road and he did it
once i said
okay let it go just don't get involved
right now
and he started coming up again when he
came up the next time i almost wrecked
and i got out of it he started coming up
a third time by this time i grabbed my
gun and he started coming up i stuck my
gun out the window
because i was no longer going to take
this and
he it frightened him he went
westbound in eastbound traffic whoa to
get away from me went up
beverly and gearheart went up gearhart
and but i didn't care i got a license
plate number
good witness went to the station you're
a good witness he was a good witness
wrote up a report there's a that's an
assault with a deadly weapon using his
vehicle as the weapon
and then told the guys that were going
out nice
there's a reward if you find this car
and they found the car
later on they hooked him up he was
juvenile they hooked up his dad because
his dad started coming out and getting
in the way hey what are you doing with
my son what are you doing with this car
he had to
hook them up to and mom was the only one
that stood out of it
and the kid was sighted out when he came
back on monday with mama
mama went in there and she said yeah
some guy pulled a gun on him and he's
trying to get away
and he said well just so happened the
guy who tried to pull the gun on was a
cop
and he's trying to run off the road by
the way he's the one that wrote up the
report
and he's here right now would you like
me to bring him in and she looked at him
and she said
no you don't have to i know because he
didn't tell me that
all this gone on it was him and she says
if you weren't here she says i beat the
[ __ ] at him right now in front of me
in front of you and the detective said
don't let me stop you
you know you're his mother and she
started whacking him so
it cost them the towing fees and impound
fees for his car
the arrest of his dad and the bail to
get him out
and the court that they're gonna have to
go to because he was still gonna have to
make an appearance in front of the
juvenile court
what happened to the case i don't know i
never got called to testify but
that was back in the 70s wow
so did things right and now today
you know people are pulling out guns
people are doing this i
constantly tell my wife you know don't
say nothing don't look at people
you know what if you're walking to your
car let's say you're walking to your car
uh you go to dinner with your with your
wife and there and
and you walk or you're with somebody
when you're walking you see some
some people does their will their body
language language signal that is
something
somebody have to look out for i invited
my wife right away yeah
okay i think so careful because i think
when people have
bad intentions i think they their body
language will say
we'll say that like if somebody walks up
and goes hey man can i talk to you for a
second like you
i think that something can happen there
was an infamous family
in east l.a it was about four or five
boys and they had a daughter yes no
close close uh right there from oyomata
they were from loyola and so this family
they were there and one of them was on
one of these programs like 50 minute 20
minutes 40 minutes whatever it was
and it showed him on tv he was he was
blind and they used to hold the guys and
he'd go up there and
to rob him he would cut him he'd cut
them if necessary you know
give up your stuff they were drive-by
shootings the mother was the leader of
the group
she was like a mob barker you should go
out with them they had still plating on
their windows there were so many
drive-bys on their house
but still played it on the windows so
years go by
i'm no longer patrol and i knew the
family and when they were bad
they'd go to jail i'd take them to jail
but when they weren't bad
they were not the sharpest knife in the
drawer hey what's going on pete what's
going on
so now i'm gone i'm in homicide been
gone for years
i go to uh a big market it was like
uh maybe a gymco or something like that
it was a big
like costco is today it was one of those
big stores i remember jumpco do you know
what jumpco stand for
what uh give every mexican credit
opportunity
[Laughter]
got through it so i i see these guys
and they see me i see two of them and
they're walking towards me and i'm in
the market i'm in the store and i don't
have a gun on me
and they're walking at me and they're
just kind of looking at making eye
contact
and i'm saying okay let's look look at
my surrounding and i look at my
surroundings
and two of the other brothers are
walking behind me so they've got me
closed and
they're coming in and i stop
and i'm figuring they're small guys so
i'm just figuring out how many
get away from this you know get out of
it and they said hey
remember us careel i said yeah
i remember you like that yeah and i said
yeah i remember you why
and then one brother hit the other side
i told you holmes he'd remember us
i told you he says he's bad hey
and we want you to know we're proud of
you hey we see you on tv now you're
kicking ass i said
you're good and so
they they remembered me and i i thought
it was going to get physical
no they just wanted to see if i remember
them because i was like their friend but
you know what i think i think that
you're
a made man in law you know you know how
rich ramirez had
a lot of respect for for frank because
he worked on the on the hillside
strangler
and he wanted to know questions like
that i think because you helping to
apprehend somebody told me that the
people in east l.a
caught the nightstalker right
physically they did physically they did
yeah and then he got
pulled out of the sheriff's vehicle into
the lapd that's right
when he got pulled over he was in the
sheriff's vehicle and he said it's me
man it's me but
the sheriff was only on the job for like
a week yeah he was
he was a rookie he was working a one-man
day car you train
with a two-man car you imagine that when
you finally get out training they kick
you to a one-man day car to see if you
can do it on your own i want my daycar
so he's like
he's asking the questions like who are
you and like he just has no idea
so richard is like it's me man it's me
and he's like
who are we who because i'm here did we
hang out
i don't know if i've ever told you this
but when lapd got there
the cop that led the charge the guy that
was in charge of all the patrol guys
that said get him out of his car take
him
his name was george lopez it was alex
yeah lapd guy george lopez good
friends they pulled him out of the
chef's car put him in an labpd car and
took him to uh hollenbeck
if the sheriff had him where was he
going to go to the sheriff's office
stations totally stationed 50193rd
street
but not the lap not holland no hinaganda
already should have got ours
and the guys from east l.a the patrol
guys they were pissed off at
that george lopez it's the biggest
arrest in the history of the county and
you let him go how did you let him go
you know
and and they were pissed off but i i
just i think we should interview that
george
they just snatched them out of their
heart they just took them out of the car
kept them cuffed right somebody
wrapped his head though somebody put
bandages on his yeah that was his they
the the husband of the lady tried to
carjack he hit him in the head game of
koscoron and then
he was already tired he had been running
jumping fences across freeway
he's exhausted they surround him they
hold him right there
and he was running he ran across the
freeway andy ramirez uh
andy ramirez got there called for
paramedics because he did have the
cut on the head yeah so they put the
turban on his head
and he's sitting there as j as andy is
taking information
on what we would call a gimme arrest the
citizens you know they're the ones that
he just needed some information they
called it in and he's doing this when
jordan lopez and the blue meanies got
there and george says yeah that's the
guy we've been chasing the blue meanies
so they took him away the blue minis are
lapd well that's what i call them
so so they caught the uh um the um
golden state killer by somebody doing
like 23 and me
what's 23 million like a dna that's what
yeah dna yeah they caught them through
the dna
yes because it's because you're sending
in voluntarily dna they call it familiar
dna
yeah so it's a way to check in the box
you can share your data he sent
in or they had a group a family member
you know when you put the
you send in your you want to find out
what your
lineage is you send in your family tree
well all that's held and so when they
had dna
there's put it in the dna search it hit
on a
hit over here that's a family member so
then they just had to find out the
family member who was linked up together
so following the family member is what
led to him yes
yeah and it was just like by sheer
chance that this family member took
because they just wanted to find out
like oh am i
actually polish or some [ __ ] like that
and they just submitted their
thing to 23 may figure out what they're
like but you know it seems to be fun for
people to find out what they are but you
have to remember
people that are out there that that
information goes to the authorities as
well
and it's it's available to them that's
why i don't care who where i came from
i'm here i'm important i don't care what
happened and you know that's dna that's
not
addresses and names that's you that's
you that's how they caught that dude
that cop was like let's see if you know
there's a
a match how great for that though oh did
you think that the zodiac killer was a
police officer
i think that the zodiac killer was a
police officer i i don't know i followed
the zodiac uh
and and there's just been so much some
guy finally came forward a few years ago
said it was my dad
and he tells a story and it's a very
compelling story was he was he a police
officer
no and
but the lady that answered the the lady
that answered the call
because zodiac killer called the police
station
he had a voice and he said good bye
like that like very eerie and she did it
she goes i'm going to tell you the way
he did good
goodbye that
if i was one of the police officers i'm
not but you know in another life i was a
detective
i would have gotten all the police
officers to say certain words
and then i think it was a police officer
because how do you stay one step ahead
of the police if you're not
an officer yourself i should say alleged
[ __ ] guess they never
so so they never found um zodiac they
haven't positively identified them no
they're they're still working on i know
they're still working
they like just cracked one of his
letters i feel like a couple years ago
yeah but also
there's got to be dna and footprints and
all that stuff right i i don't know
because i wasn't privy to all the
evidence and if they're good cops who
wouldn't release all that stuff to the
public
like dianne feinstein did when the
zodiac killer was out there even though
he was in san francisco i'd be walking
down from baseball practice
you know sometimes it gets dark like at
4 30 in the afternoon i would see a man
watering the grass and i thought it was
a zodiac killer [ __ ] take up
run run through traffic and everything i
was scared as [ __ ]
when i was working i was working
murderers zodiac killers the first case
that really intrigued me
still does today it it really did this
it's an intellectual guy right i think a
lot of the serial killers are not yeah
he's not stupid you know he did what he
did he was writing the newspaper
you know he did this the btk buying them
torture kill him do anything about the
btk killer
no that was a guy from he was he killed
over a period of 30 years
several women and when he when he
finally got captured it was because
he wrote a letter to the press wondering
hey if i
send you something via computer would
you be able to track it
and he said no well he didn't know
enough about computers to know that he
could
and they tracked the computer to uh the
church
and who had access to the computer well
this guy did
when they finally got it and the guy
copped out everything eventually
he was a deacon he was a boy scout
master
he worked for the local animal control
to go out and give tickets like this
harvey milk toast everyday type guy you
never know it
i just got done speaking in austin and
had i not been drinking so much wine the
night before
his daughter was at the same event
and she was i wish i had gone to see her
i
because i was called i was actually
called to go consult with those people
out there
so his daughter his daughter dennis
rader
uh his daughter's face his daughter
is going out on the speaking yes she's
speaking to her she was there you could
be
clear dennis writer was the btk yeah
yeah and he wanted to be a police
officer he ended up being a
almost like a animal control animal
control but he'd write you a ticket if
you're
yeah grass was too long or your shrubs
were too high he was just one of those
power
he wanted to do it with power there was
a serial killer in uh in new york when i
was a kid
and they used to call him charlie
chopper and he used to
he had mutilated like kids were yours
with that charlie
this was like in the 70s before your
time papa
um and so
so we were like eight nine years old in
the neighborhood
and so we would all get together as a
gang and like try to stick together
because charlie chopper
was grabbing little boys and cutting
their privates and doing crazy stuff
so the whole i mean the upper west side
was
you know on lockdown for at least six
months and they put up posters all over
the place
they had descriptions of this guy i'm
not sure if they ever found them
but uh yeah charlie chap i wonder just
in one area or to the whole
well you know i never left my block 108
amsterdam
broadway you know what i'm saying when
you live in new york it's interesting
but you
you kind of don't leave your block no no
your school's across the street
but people are more familiar because
they live on top of each other right
right
and here there you don't need a car and
you would walk to school and
you could live downtown and you usually
knew who the weird people in the
neighborhood
are yeah you know watch out for cedric
you know that too that dude is weird but
you knew that he wasn't charlie chopper
you know
but then also everybody was always
looking out the window so somebody's
trying to pull some [ __ ] or somebody was
to break into somebody's i don't think
they broke into someone's house during
the day of course
always out there going yelling at him
yelling at me
right there so here nobody really pays
attention nobody's really paying
attention
looked it up still considered an open
case someone confessed i'm not sure
when but they were deemed uh unfit for
trial and sent back to the mental
institution they were in
that was charlie chopper charlie chop
off it says i don't know if that was
another
the name i think charlie chopper is like
an amusement ride
but charlie charlie chop off maybe but
yeah it says he was active
uh 1972 through 1973. well you know
people are fascinated with
with crime and docuseries about crime
you are fascinated with this people
you most people aren't i didn't realize
how many people were fascinated until
this documentary went on how many people
are really passionate but i was i've
really been
surprised now on on on see i would like
to be one of those people that
is not
so every time i see her watching the
next 48 hours
oh my god you got to get her on here she
she'll talk she'll talk murderers with
you all day
yeah i think yeah i think but you know
he you know gill right he caught the
bridge yeah yeah yeah yeah you have so
much knowledge
on serial killers you know the one i've
talked to you today for you to just jump
out with a name like dennis rader
i was called as a consultant on the case
i don't even remember the guy's name
because it wasn't my case
you know i just went to console i i btk
is much easier for me did you ever hear
did you ever hear him confess in court
he remembered everything
i oh yeah he did i and i've watched uh a
little documentary on him he stood there
for he stood there for hours and he said
uh a fantasy a fantasy a sexual fantasy
sir
and he just went through so articulate
sure with no
amazing oh yeah uh yeah i tied her up
and uh
and i did that now now the guys that are
sort of nomads and they just
travel throughout those are the ones
that are difficult
to catch once they have a residency you
have to be careful also because the
answer
some guy from texas there were two guys
from texas and uh what about when you go
camping man
do you don't you don't you don't feel
weird on those campsites no no no
everybody's friendly yeah everybody's
friendly at campsites every year
they're retired these are people
easygoing they spend a lot of money on
their
on their coaches and they just want to
have someone just want to release
sometimes but if you're at a campsite
and somebody shows up with a like a
hatchet
and a mask it's probably not a good
thing but they're [ __ ] around like
those clowns used to do like in the
middle of the night they go
knock on people's doors yeah or stand in
the middle of the street
don't be a clown and knock on my door in
the middle of the night i'm telling you
right now brother
you know that you know how those clowns
would chase people
i need to do the clown chasers you ain't
going to chase me i'm not that fast i
don't think that's
what do you do you pray pray pray that
he doesn't catch you yeah
there there's you know you you have the
right to everybody has right to defend
them so i'll do whatever you do
you know like a trap rat you know you're
much bigger than a rat when you get that
rat in the corner rat's gonna do
everything he can to get away from you
a cat will do the same thing if it means
jumping out at you
you know he's got the element of fear on
his side so he's in control
once that element of fear is gone then
you're on a level a little more level
playing field
so do what you got to do but also you
know also if you have lights around your
house or the driveway and you walk into
somebody's house and the lights go off
that will deter people from [ __ ] with
you if they can go on the side of your
house and it's dark
i got to tell you does it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter because we had this
crazy
uh stalking our home and the cameras
would show him
[ __ ] four three in the morning just
not on your property
right outside yeah okay inside one of
the gates
yeah just sort of still walking it right
outside the house
so it can get a little spooky what do
you do if you have somebody camping
outside your house
and they know the limits but they're
there and they're antagonizing you maybe
they're filming you
maybe they're asking you questions you
walk to the car you go to an appointment
they follow you to the appointment what
but technically it's not
criminal they're just going where you go
but you know they're going it's
specifically you it's not it just so
happens to be you
it's you what what what do you do
there's too many questions to ask about
that that that's a heavy question
trust me you wouldn't be following me
too long you know
it would be over but they're looking for
you to make to do something to do that
sure they're trying to learn yes
absolutely and tifa they're doing the
same thing you know
they're following people getting you
know they uh
on the freeways one time they put
sheriff vianova's address
you know painted you know put a big sign
here's his address you know they're
trying to get to him
and they couldn't but they wanted it and
they're following him and they go out
and they park in front of your house
uh people come nobody fortunately
nobody's come i'm not that important
hung around
so you were a sheriff so you're you're
you're a sheriff hundred percent right
yes
so alex villanueva the the sheriff
people are on his ass yes you're a
supporter of the sheriff i'm a supporter
of
alex villanova for share of 2022 2020 do
you think that he would come on this
on this show i i don't know you know i
talked to him about being on the show
matter of fact i i talked to him after
the after i was i
think when you're out there covering
because you're out there doing
engagements you're out there talking to
the world and luncheons and going to
i told you i was emcee for a car show a
couple of weeks ago this dude is there
like uh bert park see
yeah nobody even knows you want to come
post my night tonight at the selfie tour
that's another place let's go hey that's
another place i want you to go
let's go to the sophie towel over there
um on beverly and la cienega i'm in you
might have taken nap though it's late
they started
tonight we start around nine okay
but we go till two well let's wait till
we get out of we might still be here at
night
for the questions that i'm asking yeah
so
i gave a shout out and i
because i'm not this camera stuff you
know i
push the video and i'm talking to the
crowd i said all right everybody let me
let's have your attention
i want everybody to watch george lopez
oh my god hi
i've been on the show with him he's a
great guy i wish he could have been here
today he's got other commitments
couldn't make it
how about a shout out how about a round
of applause for jordan lopez and
everybody start cheering and everything
and then i looked at my camera to watch
it later on
you know we'll get to you uh you know
two hours in the
when when the when the detective when
the series came out of netflix you know
my publicist like you you got to see
this thing you'll love it
and i watched it all the way through so
i saw gil but i knew frank his partner i
knew frank helped me out
like 11 years ago or something i call
frank frank's great always
available man those dudes when you're
when you're like a high-profile police
officer or a detective
and somebody calls you they answer the
phone because
it's kind of what they're used to you
know they're not like oh i'm retired
he says hello hey frank it's jorge
what's up joe are you still talking to
gil
yeah i still still going occasionally
you might give him the info man to see
and then he called me and then they
thought it was a prank and i didn't call
him back
you know for a month and then here he is
man here we are
i even made it through the ear to the
billboard right there oh my god
big bad dyke over there all the youtube
comments if you're ever like not on or
something like that they're like bring
back gail so how come this [ __ ] 200
degrees in here because i'm wearing a
jacket
probably the jacket might be apart do
you have the ac rolling aaron
[ __ ] lower maybe make it we'll
we'll talk louder i had something in
mind something wrong with my eye oh yeah
how's that doing
and i thought i could do it myself
[ __ ] got worse
it's like having a [ __ ] heirloom
tomato on your [ __ ] eyelid
so yesterday the did you have like a
little stir or something yeah not a
little one
the guy came to my house and did it on
my balcony now they're doing uh
optometry at the house
you took care of it i uh numbed it
usually
you wouldn't let anybody near your eye
on your balcony what do they do
too he flipped it with a he held it with
a clamp flipped it under and then cut it
like rocky should just flew out i was uh
asked to be the principal today at an
elementary school
so it's all done via via zoom so i'm on
there and one of the things i did was i
read a book to
a kindergarten class and i had a style i
had never had a style before in my life
but i had a stye and so
i read the book to these kids and they
said okay kids that was
uh mr carrillo do you have any questions
for mr carrillo
one little girl raised her hand she had
a question asian
and i couldn't understand her so i asked
the teacher i said
what did she say she says i really don't
know and little johnny at the back of
the class sitting next to her says i
know what she said and he said
what is it jenny he said what happened
to his eye
she could see the sky yeah they're nice
it was nasty
is it because you're fingering your kudo
and then you rub your eyes that's why
that
happened that's why i just changed
fingers
there you go that's what happens to you
in the itchy butt you wake up with
smelly fingers
yeah you watch tv you're not even you're
not even aware that you're you're
touching your lower extremities and
you're going like this
no wonder remotes you know if if you do
the test on the remote
it's got so much stuff on it i did the
dr oz show via zoom
i still have the style and he says how
you doing i said well [ __ ] i got this
thigh doc i don't know if you want to do
the show can you see
he says it really isn't that bad he said
let me give you a word of device right
now i said what's that
he said warm compacts put the warm
compacts on there
it'll go away not a problem no and it's
underneath though
mine uh might as well weigh my
mind for i had mine since the middle of
april
oh really i hadn't noticed and it wasn't
going away really
and finally they cut does it
hurt or you said that numbed it up like
i just don't want to even pick it they
numbed it up they got to talk around he
numbed it up and then he flipped it and
cut it
when is it going to be uh available for
presentation uh december no okay
uh who in your family was musical
who in my family you know you said
genealogy
was it was your dad into was what did
your dad do for a living my dad was a
labor wrong
grandfather my grandfather was a he
wrote he was my grandfather was a vista
but he was a musician yeah did you know
your grandfather yes
and your grandmother yes i but they i
found out later when i was in
i think i was in germany when i'm
talking to my mom on the phone and she's
crying because
she found out that my mom that her
mother and father my grandfather and
grandmother
had never legally gotten married so
she's crying says i'm a bastard i'm a
bad i said oh come on mom you know it's
interesting that two people back then
yeah they they never got me
and i found out my grandfather was like
a rolling stone you know he
he had kids all over the west southwest
you know and he was
one day i used to have a horse and i
rode the horse down my mom's
and he was there for me one day used to
have a horse nobody
you just had a horse growing up yeah and
no not growing up i was an adult i
bought the horse
and i loved the world i had a horse and
then you know and i bought it from
acharo and
i love charos and i love the i love the
culture everything i wrote down my mom's
because
where i had them stable wasn't too far
away from my mom's house i roomed at my
mom's house my grandfather was there
and he came out there and he started
looking he started telling me about that
for
confirmation of the hind legs and this
and that and also my mom said how does
he know so much
and she says
she wanted my grandfather to tell me he
says you told him when he was an adult
you would talk to him
so he took me into the house he sat me
down and all in spanish he told me that
he never wanted to tell me this because
he didn't want me to grow up like him
and he used to be a vista he came to the
united states running from the
federalists and
in mexico to get away over here and i
find out he was a hell of a knife man
you know that was especially the
trombone player and he's right horses
never wanted me to be anything like him
and i was so proud i don't know that's
pretty cool i
was so proud man my grandfather was a
beast it was bad he was
bad dude you know but i still like my
horrors i don't care what he said
that's why i gave you that i wanna want
a poster the pancho veal poster from the
revolution
who would your family tell me because
you just don't become musical well
actually that that's a question that's a
good question but my dad sang his ass
off
but he never got to fulfill any of his
dreams but his best friend do you want
to do what was his dream
he wants to sing he wants to sing like
santito colon
you guys don't know who that is but
santito colon was tito puente's lead
singer for years and
the one that didn't sing right he was
just a percussionist he was a
percussionist
so uh tito puente la lupe santos colon
they would all come over to the house
after the gig and of course i was just a
kid so i'd wake up at six
uh you know at three or four in the
morning and i'm
all of seven eight years old and tito
puentes there they would give me
quarters so i could send my ass back to
the bed you know so
stop leaving alone but
i never understood why everybody came to
my house
after the gig and they would be smoking
these little cigarettes you know
which the clothes huh weed or they were
like weeds
okay so our house was the party house
and there was singing and we were
playing guido and so
that's where i got all my musicality
from but unfortunately my
my pops passed when i was 11 and i
didn't get to see tito puente again for
like
another 10 years because you know you
get lost in the whole
who's taking care of the kids you know
we were all orphans at that point
um and then i ended up 20 years
later at 11 and then how did he can i
ask how he passed
he had a liver condition from the korean
war
and back then uh if you had hep c
that's it you're done thank you thank
you for a service
yeah it was thank you thank you for your
service yeah yeah because but now
with one injection you know people are
actually saying back then you were
yellow and you
got john yeah yeah yeah yeah so he
passed he passed due to uh
liver malfunction um and he wasn't
really a huge
drinker and stuff so you know if my
father was an alcoholic i could sort of
accept it you know but the fact that he
had contracted that
from uh i believe rusty
cans in the korean war they open up
those cans they eat whatever's in there
and so he had contracted some sort of
uh whatever and it affected his liver
but i truly believe that had my dad
stuck around
i would have been recording with tito
early on and all that other stuff
but i did get a chance to be on on a
record with tito puente
um but after he passed you stayed music
you stayed musical right you stayed in
school you graduated from high school
you left school
no i um i was going to music and art
um in in new york and then i
i i in my senior year i was so tired of
school
that i walked across the street to city
college i took my ged class
my test wow i passed my and that that's
it
i'm gone so i didn't want anything to do
with school
um and just started you know gigging and
and i just i just love the music you
know and so
from there i had to play give him where
though
oh like just little local places like
the barn
club exactly exactly but
manhattan college had had their end of
year
festivities guess who was the band i was
playing
willie colon and hector lavo singing
can you imagine that you know about
hector level no i don't know about
hector i know about
tito and cologne when i was a kid i used
to my sister used to listen to a lot
when they used to play at our lady at
lord's church
every year twice a year you know he'd be
over there and i love this music i
remember hearing
didn't become famous until santana
covered it
uh and then they go then when they told
santana they go i'm going to cover
oyakomovan he goes
he goes that's not rock and roll and
carlos goes not yet
i'm talking about the phone
which you and i have to cover we're
going to do it i'm still working on it
oh yeah i'm gonna go play guitar with
them on on a wednesday
can you imagine let me know i'm gonna
i'm gonna break out a little come over
right now before we go let's go
but so then from then did you did you
have friends that
that went with you that were like
support
i had a friend growing up that we went
to the comedy store
in may 5th of 1979 i wouldn't have gone
by myself but he was like
the guy that would go with me my friend
ernie and then
somehow we drifted apart so
when i started doing stand-up for a
living he was never around and then when
i got my show he wasn't around
or through any of the stuff and he
should have been i think
we're not we're not friends anymore but
two guys grow up and one guy wants to be
a comedian the other guy's like i'll go
with you and then
he does it that dude's not around like
it's weird
you have friends that went with you that
my brother no it was my
my older brother he was older by two
years and he's the one who sort of
encouraged
we were working as butchers in new york
at that time
from 16 to 21 i was a butcher and he
and he managed the butcher's store so
after so many years working as a butcher
look at these damn hands all messed up
uh he's like yo let's go to california
so that you can realize your dreams
i'm like oh okay wow so we jumped on a
bus for 69
on a greyhound bus and it took us three
days from new york
to california you still remember i still
remember leaving new york i still
remember that day oh yeah
yeah it's crazy crazy hot it's crazy
crazy man because you know we're from
here but people like he took a bus with
his brother
comes out here where'd you guys land
down in there no we ended up in san
francisco because i had a
one of my brothers was living up in in
sonoma county
um up by a santa rosa
and so he was the only puerto rican
oh yeah but he used to work as a
translator between the mexican community
and the white comedic it was all it was
nothing but blanco's up there and it was
almost like wine country migrants and
yeah
exactly so uh so we stopped off in san
francisco to visit him for a little
while before i was going to be on my way
to los angeles to sort of realize my
dreams
and um i ended up booking a show in san
francisco
and then you know it was beach blanket
babylon which is the longest running
uh show that san francisco had i think
that show ran for like
30 years where was that down in the
italian district right on green street
at the fugazi theater it's
it was a great show really theater
really really interesting show um
and it was just all about uh i played
springsteen and stallone
and there was other characters also
there was also it was like the legends
it was like the legends there were other
people playing michael jackson
and some lady came out in a bush uh
outfit and she was barbara bush for some
bit
uh it was just song and dance and uh and
a funny show
which you were working but i was
auditioning for it
i auditioned for it yeah i auditioned
for it i lied about everything
they wanted they wanted a picture they
wanted a resume and they wanted a
a prepared song i didn't have any of
that so i just showed up
with a story oh my god my car broke down
i left all my stuff i don't have
anything with me but here i am
let's go do you have a monologue uh yeah
i just made this [ __ ] up as i went along
oh my god
do you have a song yeah uh i ended up
singing um
an algero tune which is not an easy song
to sing
i can remember the days in december the
leaves are brown
on the ground and the dude was like all
right
still sound good today yeah yeah what
about like was he scat he was kind of
scared huh
yeah he was one of the baddest uh
jerome's
he was a man i i met al jarrod at the
playboy jazz festival jacqueline
you know older little spine benz but he
was still
he was still amazing oh man vocally he
was he was pretty incredible amazing he
was pretty incredible
so i ended up booking the show and i and
i just started working in theater
um i ended up staying in san francisco
for a solid
10 years i worked with the california
shakespeare company with
you know uh the berkeley uh shakes and
all that other stuff
i was a thespian yeah and i didn't
realize that really if you wanted to be
a thesman you have to get your ass to
los angeles to do film and television
because
all that but you were studying acting
and music acting in music
yeah yeah and then you went to
so then i came to los angeles but you
weren't married over there you weren't
married before
no but i had a couple of i had a baby
mama though yeah that had
a you know a couple kids um
because you know how it is you know
when you're out there performing what
else is there to say females will find
you and you will find them
and sometimes uh you know that 99.9
percent
uh pill effectiveness
doesn't work and so you end up with a
kid yeah that's okay
i have four i wouldn't have it any other
way i love i love the way my life turned
it is i mean you know people get upset
or they're like but you know it turns
it turns out like that like you know so
then you come out here
so then i come out here and i start
singing at a little place called florida
in hollywood on what on vine and
fountain yeah
all right la foreign
yeah so okay uh and everybody went to
everybody everybody's kidding i'm
singing this
in this little hole in the room in the
world you've been there
mick jagger jumps on stage with me there
wow everybody a young jennifer lopez a
young sama hyatt i mean everyone used to
go to florida
and a very young leah remedy walked in
and the rest is history what year was
that was leah working out six
was leah working already no she was
about to get king of queens
when i met leah she booked a show julia
reminius
yeah actress actress yeah she was in
king of queens and
uh for forever and uh she was in uh old
school
amazing in old school great great great
great performance funny
um tough cookie i would say
oh yeah she's a pretty she's a tough
cookie man she's tough yeah you don't
want to be
fair you don't want to mess with wifey
okay
yeah as a matter of fact we met each
other and then we reconnected because i
was watching something and i
called him and just said to talia that i
think she's the most one of the most
courageous people
right now i mean so so they were
and then i'd met him before but never
gotten the story so
la florida and then yeah and jennifer
and leah were friends at that time i'm
sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah um and we were
friends with mark and jennifer and you
know we just
every everything was great we um
i mean you know listen we're 25 years in
it i picked the right one if you know
what i mean because when you're sitting
there
and you have all these young starlets
and every
the who's who in this place it's easy to
get lost in in all that
right but there was something special
about leah maybe it was when she met me
and said hey when are we getting married
i don't know you know what i've never
had a woman say that to me but
was that her opener that was so
beautiful i think it's beautiful
that's her that was her opener to me
when are we getting when are we getting
married
big moves you got to respect that it
worked out like you said it
worked out i i laughed i said no you
could because i already have three kids
she's like okay 25 years later and a 17
year old daughter i think uh
i think i think we're gonna make it good
but you recorded me you you recorded
music and everything right you
you so much first so when i got to san
francisco my first professional
recording was with [ __ ] santa maria
wow peter scovito he wasn't using
singers at the time but i was new to the
bay area so pete was like yo who's this
new young singer
boom he introduced me to mongol i
recorded with [ __ ]
um you remember bill graham of course of
course
so bill graham the biggest rock promoter
in the world right
so we're celebrating his birthday
um there was an all old um
mafioso by the name of perito pelegrin
and he had
brought in all these top musicians from
puerto rico
right we were going to start a band in
the bay area
and bill graham was celebrating his
birthday so
i brought the band because bill graham
used to love to come to minot he would
love salsa he would just sit there and
just enjoy the night away right i didn't
know that he was the biggest producer in
the world i thought he was just a sweet
but he literally used to come here he's
a tough one he was a tough [ __ ] guy
but he loved music and he made the
concert business and he made
santana and journey and steve ray and
all those
guys so he asked me if i would play his
party i'm like hell yeah
who shows up santana's in the band
tito puente's in the band i'm fronting
the band
that was my band you got a shoe and i
had all these
top puerto rican musicians from from
puerto rico
man what a party we had such a great i
actually have a picture of me and tito
at that time did you play at winterline
in san francisco it's not there anymore
bimbos was the what
oh beautiful yeah yeah beautiful oh man
got that young look at that young stuff
and the tito that's great i was calling
the young stuff
so that night we're all hanging out
dancing on the dance floor and bill
graham is like yeah oh we're taking this
on the road we're gonna
and of course you know i'm a young i'm
just a young singer
in town they replaced you i'm with the
no i'm with the biggest promoter in the
world
he dies in the helicopter remember yeah
coming from shoreline
should have taken a car man should have
taken the car
but uh yeah the bay area was uh
he was coming from uh shoreline which is
near san jose back to san francisco in a
helicopter
yeah and they hit the they hit the wires
on the way up
but it's like from that close take a
[ __ ] car man
last time i saw pinto puente bill cosby
was there
they were doing uh the pasta house in
east l.a
you're just used to go there it's on
olympic boulevard
and latin groups used to go in the pasta
house look it up really
and they used to do like latin jazz yeah
they would go in there one day a week
and
bill cosby go up there and he'd let him
play with him for a while he played the
drums yeah yeah
not to drown the congas yeah would that
be betty's pasta house yes cool
yeah there it is is it still open i
think they just use it for rentals no i
don't it used to be uh
it's a banquet hall it says yeah it used
to be
betty spa's house it was a nightclub
you'd go in there and uh
only little people the mexicans with
money to go they see a lot of cadillacs
for that part of esla was unusual but
you'd see a lot of cadillac's going in
and out of the place
did you ever see santa cruz no the last
time i saw santa cruz we did we were
doing an event at the bonaventure
in the hall in the early 2000s and she
was performing
with her man in the back right there
with the suit
i left at 2 30 and she was still
up there and the last thing before i
left the room i turned and i looked and
i said
it's incredible that this woman it's 2
30 in the morning
covered in sweat jamming nobody was
leaving i think i had to work the next
day
and that's the last time i saw her but
the last time i saw her i was impressed
by her
the amount of energy that she had
i sang back up for her uh at a
performance
here in cali in uh people forgot about
celia
and she was a beast
where's that movie can we ask can we get
another one i think they did um
i think they did they did a little
series on uh on the celia journey but
i'm not
i'm not sure that they actually you know
gave it the
the quality your story would be it'd be
a good movie huh
but they don't really do those movie out
of cuba
i mean let's not forget she started in
cuba with uh sonora matanzera and
and all that before she came over here
and started recording with dietel
you know you know you know it's
unbelievable to think how many
latin performers that this world has nev
they were niche
singers and performers but they
shouldn't have been and that that
are are forgotten yeah i mean today you
know who passed today was johnny ventura
and johnny ventura uh i opened for
johnny ventura back in in
about like 30 years ago he was the top
top merengue
the top medenge singer in the world
and when i'm telling you that you should
have seen the shows that these guys were
putting on
talk about dancing movements it was
crazy johnny mantuda put on an
amazing show he's going to be missing
and how old
did he live to be eighty-one wow that's
a good yeah he said he had to go i can't
believe that i'm sitting here next to
this gentleman and i can't believe you
look at him listen to his story
but the way he says merengue cuba
puerto rican not like it's not like this
a new york accent
but with that latino role
careful you know i would say that i
would say that
the chicano is this is a distant
heritage to boricua in puerto rico and
in new york
close quarters in the bronx close
quarters with family
everybody almost living together and
here
you have to drive you go see your mom
you go see your dad oh yeah over in the
holidays it's just
every all the doors are open everybody's
cooking and the and every you can smell
everything in in the neighborhood
is way different than us than us here
yeah yeah and you go visit somebody
today you go visit your abuela or
or your or your mother or anything and
you sit there
and at the visit everybody is uh
brandon everybody's on their iphones
they're not visiting anywhere everybody
everybody's doing this everybody's on
their phone
i'm starting to get that one's orange
this one is uh yeah we got the sampler
pack back in here so
you've got the orange cream you got the
orange cream you got an orange cream
grapefruit yeah right over there
hibiscus
this is my favorite so far yeah we got
to uh one more this is
you right here if you want that's that's
the one that i like yeah it's not your
thing
yeah yeah yeah me too this is the first
time
this is good i like this but i like the
other one better it's like a creamsicle
you know the
the alcohol beverage control says you
can only have so much but you know we
don't
this goes under the radar they're pretty
they're pretty strong the beer is doing
pretty good
but but i think now that we've uh
come from you know 14 months or still
going back into a little bit of a
the delta variant that that
that's scaring the crap out of me i
don't want to hear any more of them
anymore doesn't send me a thing she's
she's on her way right now to uh dropped
off my wife took her to the airport
on our way to san francisco watching
dodgers and
well i'm sitting out here she's okay
they just announced you need to get that
third dose now pfizer's saying
their dose and now everybody you know
you better get any better yet i said hey
fda hasn't even approved it yet let them
approve it let them get out here then
i'll get it
because they're not even sure about that
yet they're saying it's
showing signs that a third dose can
enhance your chances but
but you know what they say to put a
little bit of uh what why would you guys
a little bit of purell or neosporin
under your nose
uh to kill the just under your nose
to kill them yeah because as you know
but then it looks like you've got
mortals all day
that's true but that's better than dying
i just had more clothes when i was
little
they would dry up
nobody nobody watched me so so
you ever throw a mocha at somebody
though like i've been ah
oh yeah back in the day yeah you ever
farted on stage and have somebody smell
it
hard to blame it on the dog are you
kidding chicago
i farted man i was like and i caught it
first i was like oh [ __ ]
this is not going to be good and the
front row that you see them like this
laughing is like
and you can always know where it's
coming from it's because because it
depends
on on the reaction you know the reaction
time is like
the two backup singers they go and then
the con ghetto behind them goes
and then the horns behind the congedo go
so you know it came from the front
and moved to the back yeah if if
um when you did you tour as a musician
yeah and you and you you've been in
films you've been in tv
what what makes you the i think playing
music makes you happy
oh being on stage playing music is the
happiest place in the world are you
kidding me
yeah that's why i'm trying to get you on
stage with me so we can rock it out
bubba
yeah let's go guitar how does it talk
today it's really very special over
there
we're shooting a uh i'm working on a
film right now called
shelter actually and it's a cast of like
latinos in in
a heist um it's a heist movie
uh jane ortiz from uh station 19
precinct 19. what's that show yeah um
lisa vidal she's in it
that's it i told you not to come up not
to ask me about the names
i can't remember names carlos miranda
sasha mercy
and cam chicken there you go yeah i like
that
he knew it was a test yeah
there you go um but it's a bunch of
young
cute latinos with a couple
tell me about tell me about uh because
you know we're both friends with uh mr
don cheadle
tell everybody about your meeting don
cheadle don
don is probably one of the realest
people that you're ever gonna he really
is
in your life i mean we're working on a
movie that's got a budget of a hundred
mil
right it was sword fishing swordfish so
travolta halle berry
hugh jackman and and don uh i was
sort of the the fifth wheel but uh i
came in as a day player
right to do just a couple scenes with
don and then don was like yo
i need a partner for this movie and then
they looked at me said all right well
that's it how about that he's your
partner for this movie
and four months later we're still how
about that we're still recalling
who did that soderbergh um no
um i can't remember i haven't seen him
looking at we're going to have an uh
santa senia dominic senna actually
directed it that was a but the producer
was
oh let's see joel silver joe silva yeah
big producer
yeah yeah um so so he's
so by chance because don cheadle was in
the position to say i need a partner
how about this guy and he's four months
later he's still
by his side and then they're still
friends we played golf and
as dawn asked angelo and i remember them
i said hey you guys know each other and
then
it's that great story we we had so much
uh we had so much fun on that set we
were throwing the football the baseball
playing
poker by the way don't ever play poker
against any jokes
will take your money all day long so
don't you play
yeah i never you know i lose money yeah
i don't play poker but i when i when i
have money to lose i i play
yeah yeah yeah i would want to play i
used to play a lot then you know
retirement slowed me down i don't play
that much some of the guys still get
together once
uh once a month twice a month and
they play but don played in the in in
like
poker he beat phil ivey he plays in
poker tournaments
wow and he's very musical
[Music]
he plays a little bit of everything a
little bit of sax a little bit of guitar
bass with some bass yeah yeah that's
another guy we gonna you know
let's put the band together me you and
don he's on bass you're on guitar well
you don't nobody wants to do that
anymore nobody wants to go to a place
and and you're there every wednesday
right
every wednesday you don't take a
wednesday off yeah i do from time to
time
i'll have other singers come in and i'll
just take the night off you know he's
been trying to get me over there
for years let's go but for me it's like
an industry night like
if mark anthony's in town he'll jump on
stage with me if
if um uh
anyway whoever comes in omar chapato was
there this last week
and he jumped on stage with me and we
had a blast and he's you
you know when someone is musical when
someone is musical like that like let's
say you know
those people you know i hosted the jazz
festival they're not doing it
at the hollywood bowl i think it was
almost like 40 years they're not
bringing it back
wow why i don't know the philharmonic is
different i know yeah we got it back up
we were selling out
um but what do we need do we do we just
need a venue
or i say we go to the greek you know we
have somebody that can underwrite it you
go to do it at the greek
but but i saw some incredible you know
musicians and in the beginning
um i've always loved music but i
remember seeing
playboy in 79 and seeing you know miles
davis there and seeing
sammy davis jr and bill cosby was
hosting and then
in like 12 or 13 bill cosby called me
and uh he said uh you know i'm have you
seen my chair
my and he said you know do you
i want you i'm i'm uh i'm retiring
but i think he knew what was coming in
the next year so he passed it over to me
before it was taken away from him
and um i did it for i think eight years
it was great
i did i did all the things he told me
not to do he said don't tip he said
don't let the musicians in your room
and leave right after you introduce the
last act i thought it stayed there until
2 30 in the morning i tipped everybody
and we drank in that little ass room and
smoked weed
i i got i was crazier than all the
musicians combined
quincy jones they were probably telling
the musicians yo don't let georgia
i know man as soon
i played the uh the playboy mansion once
and there was a blackout
in the middle just as we started our set
the whole place just was blacked out
so they put candles up and you know
they're like play something we're like
no microphones nothing all we have is
drums so we just started getting
roomba on them start doing
some chants i mean how did you get
booked what was that mid-summer night or
what party was that there's a party
there all the time um
i don't really know i just know when
they when the playboy
mansion called do you want to play up
since how much do i have to pay
say yes when i was married uh
they said we want you to come to the mid
summer nights uh dream the party where
and and anne goes oh i've never been to
the play match i wanted to go
and i said i told him no and she goes
why did you tell him no i said because
i'm not taking you to the [ __ ] world
i'm [ __ ] i'm not going if i get
invited to the problem i'll take you my
wife
when i got divorced i went again
and uh half was there hef and i were
cool you know
he was uh he was didn't really get up
didn't really
you know toward the end there and the
last time he was at the playground
mansion
they said introduce half and he's not
going to stand up
because you when he's older and he'll
just wave and i said
i was i got to be really good at
introductions from the talk show and all
that from
being on stage i said i'm going to give
this [ __ ] an introduction he'll
stand up
i went back to the 60s to chicago
to hide hiding the magazine between your
mattresses
so putting it in your closet the fold
out the pin up the bunny the ears the
clubs
the guy who put it together only one in
the whole world
the the the the leader of it the guy we
all grew up with the guy we owe our
our sexuality to our fetish what we like
and what we don't like
and i said mr hugh heffer and with that
he [ __ ] stood up
yeah and he went like that you got him
to stand up
when the introduction is like that
they'll stand up
that's probably the last time but you
know i think yeah
everything exactly but but i think that
those
as as those people go we're losing
people
that something was their life
like the playbook was his life now
because of the name
the hollywood bowl i don't think alleged
which is a great place
i don't think they want the association
with playboy so they
they eliminated it but
people are are passing that that was
their life musicians that are passing
that
that's what they did and they're being
replaced with people that synthesize and
push a button and
you know nobody that plays nobody no
musicians play
anymore really i mean you know
you get a dj and vegas that literally
press play
that's a dude they
and god bless him man four thousand to
twelve thousand dollars
a ticket or the pool parties in vegas
during the day they're
a grand to get in yeah wow and it's just
it's just beats you know i mean you're
gonna say it like that but they
they right yeah there's not it's not a
band not instruments
am i glad i don't look good in speedos
that's what the pool parties
i'll get you a big i'll get you a gold
hat one piece
but right so so i commend you for for
keeping live music alive oh thank you
bubba
you know i'm honored i i'm just honored
to be here
with the both of you the uh the
the interesting thing about our lifetime
think about
all the things that we actually got to
witness up close and personal
that you know like our grandchildren are
going to be reading about
the playboy mansion and all these other
things that existed way back when
and the ice caps i went to a battle of
the bands
between harry james and woody herman
what was that at the palladium no
it was that the theater is not even
there it was a theater in the round in
covina
they don't do that anymore was that like
the celebrity theater
i don't know what the name of it i was i
was still in high school a theater there
was a theater in the round out there i
think it was called
where where it was it was incovina
okay and and they said woody herman won
only because he had a drummer playing
with him
buddy rich the carousel uh the carousel
that was it
the carousel he had buddy rich playing
drums for him that night
and so those are you you don't see that
that's the ticket
inshallah remember that was too too long
ago i remember going to see buddy rich
again and i took my wife with me it was
a place called
uh the topper the top hat it was in the
city of rosemead
uh right just west of rome who was in
[ __ ] rosemary herman was in rosemead
no no woody herman was at the carousel
buddy rich
was now running his own band come on man
and he went to play there and i took
and i remember he started playing and at
his first song he's playing
and he said hold on hold hold on stop
stop stop stop he says
i'm buddy rich i came here to play for
you guys you guys either shut the [ __ ]
up or get the [ __ ] out
or i'll leave hey that's what i said and
when he did that
and i how about that i said that and i
got a tmz he said it and what everybody
shut the [ __ ] up
yeah and then bam he took off it was a
great show
but that was you could do that stuff i
guess then
you can't do it anymore but but i was a
teenager then
so now you guys talking about all this
stuff and i get to see
these were old guys it just wasn't the
latino or the jazz stuff but did you
ever see liz zapp led zeppelin
no who did you go see as a kid at
concerts
temptations temptation i i saw
back then i was in the 60s i was in the
motel he went to vietnam
i was in in the motown i went to see the
temptation i bet i've seen the
temptation matter of fact they're going
to be
there's only one of them left but the
group's going to be playing some place
over here
he should be that temptation there you
go that temptation
i've seen him at least six times and i
went to see him three times in a row
with three different ladies one right
after him and the last one was the one
that i ended up getting married to
hey there's nothing was out there
he's got some stories he's been married
no wonder you got him on your pocket oh
this guy's
he's he's the greatest i love you uh
and how long have you been married fifty
years so fifty he's got many
years he's got you
i'm 25. he's like double he doubled down
he lapped you in marriage he laughed at
me
and you know they're they're still uh
very much it's a beautiful family
that's beautiful they do things as a
family the grandkids yeah
he's you gotta go tonight with a uh
you're gonna see more i'm gonna go see
momo tonight with my daughter and my
son-in-law well you went to go see
angela johnson too i went to se
angeles uh sunday did you go out this
much before or
or it's been since january when it comes
to comedy i love we always
i love comedy and like i said when i
when i saw
the first time i did this show i paid
good hard-earned money to see you at
least six times you know uh to go see
the show i
and you never asked for a refund bella
never never never i mean
laughter is is healing it's it's good
for you yeah and
i love it i went there and then i can't
believe i didn't hear you laughing as
big as you laugh i would have said
the [ __ ] is that laughing at me it was
fun no i always gave her my
my my all not like right now yeah you
i went to your show a couple of weeks
ago
and you said you heard me live because i
did i did it it was funny
it was great to have you there
yeah angela was good the other night and
tonight we're looking forward to go see
momo hey
he gets out there man he's not like us
or like me
but momo he's out there in brea right
yes
that's like an hour away something like
that he has to work near urgent care
because
that's not okay no no no no no no no no
it's out there yeah brielle's way out
he's worried he's working the one thing
i was thinking about momo is that he's
like it's not sold out
and then you know i wanted to say i'm
assuming tomorrow i said
what what what makes you think that it
would it would sell out like you just
can't take it for granted he goes oh
it's not
it's not sold out i do what the [ __ ]
what's what's this
it's a wednesday night you would never
think you never want to assume you're
going to sell it
nobody knows he hasn't had a show hasn't
had a specialist like
you take what you get you can't say oh
it's not sold out yeah
been a gas on the pocket if it's not
sold out then he didn't do proper
uh advertising not better yeah get on
the phone let's go oh yeah meet
angelo just just lie and buy a couple
tickets
how big is the place that you work angel
um i'll get anywhere from about
350 of them
i think the most that ever showed up was
on a halloween night i think we did like
750 people in that place
yeah it was packed to the gills though
but people had to sort of climb
all over each other but um yeah
regularly i'll do about 400 people on on
a wednesday where do those people come
from they go over because there's
there's a lot of
it's a nice it's a nice mix of latinos
european the brothers show up
you know it's it's a nice people dress
up
uh some people dress up and others are
just casual like us it's
what do you wear i'm casual you are yeah
like jeans no no not jeans but you know
but not white shirt
nice casual yeah but i don't like
dressing up with the suits and stuff
yeah i don't go all out because it just
gets too hot for me on stage you know
a lot you know i don't know he forget it
yes he can dance it's not like us
[Laughter]
yo i really like this one who's the
craziest who's the funniest one of the
under underrated fun mark anthony
mark you and i both know that mark
anthony is one of the funniest
people on the planet and a lot of people
don't
know this but the only way to really
capture that because you can't script
that
no you can't script it but i don't want
to tell you my idea between
me you and mark because you know then
somebody will steal no no no no
but i think genuinely when someone has a
sense of humor you can't hide the sense
of humor no matter no matter what they
do
he there's a lot of people that are
funny as much as i'm an introvert
i i have a sense of humor that joe
you do yeah that never trust me you do
yeah
but even though i'm home most of the
time by myself i i still
you know you're making it funny you make
yourself
laugh that's what matters i sit down and
i get like i can sit down and i write
stuff
but do you ever turn to yourself and say
god damn you're funny
i think so i laugh at this i laugh at
myself
that's how that that's how much i i can
remember being
in reno where i'd been up all night we
had been drinking we were
it was what days were those coming up in
the 80s right now i can't get you to
go anywhere it was it was a uh homicide
convention
a bunch of homicide crops there that
sounds like a party
that's what it is it's it's a three-day
drunk
and i mean we're up there i got there
and been up all night
and now i'm getting ready my my partner
called me and said hey let's go out we
gotta
six in the morning i says come on get
your ass out so i got in the shower
and i get in the shower and i had to
step out of the tub and when i stepped
out of the tub is slippery
and i and i fell i fell and i tried to
grab on they had showered her tried to
grab on
couldn't hold on scrape the [ __ ] out of
my arm landed on my
didn't hit my face landed hit my arms
down slapped the ground
and as soon as i'm down there nobody
else is in the room with me
first thing i said was safe and i
started laughing
if anybody could see me now you know i
was safe though or you were you that
just happened to be on this side no i
was still drunk i hadn't had time to be
cruel yet
uh yeah you remember those days when you
when
when you wouldn't go to bed and you were
still still drunk in the morning
those were awesome i do
i say it and i smile my wife doesn't
smile for good times i know the wife's
wives don't never get those things
when we go to the lab factory before the
pandemic we would
go to ihop right there on la cienega in
santa monica and we'd probably get home
at five like we'd stay in that club
there
like we did drink it in there yeah until
two thirty three o'clock in the morning
i could stay i can hang i can do that
stuff
it just there's no place you know we we
haven't gotten any place to do it and
when i do that
most of the time the wife won't you know
she didn't go with me yeah and now she's
more concerned about okay
just call us and we'll go pick you up or
you know uber
yeah you know because and the last thing
i want to do now
especially i don't want to hurt anybody
on the road i don't want to drink when
i'm driving
no so it's just not worth it but i still
go i i
i have fun i do there's nothing better
than
seeing a live performance yes nothing
better than seeing
listen to music and i think if we're
going to survive
all of this variance and all these
things that
you know once we get protected and all
that that
you know the hollywood ball open i'll go
get my third five shot at your place
we'll go down under one's
yeah we'll go make a day of it yeah make
it david
i don't know i was on the way down here
i was even thinking you know like you
say you're an interviewer you stay in
your house all day yeah
how does somebody like you that has so
much notoriety how do you go out and
pull how do you go out and have a
have a good time i can go out and
but you how do you go out you can't well
i have a vip section for him
and security so i'll keep him protected
you know it i don't really it's a trip
though when you go to some
some place and they either hear your
voice or
because you can't imagine it you don't
think you ever think you know you're
going to go into a place
and sometimes i don't go in somebody
goes someplace and there's people in
there i'll be like i'm not going to go
in there
and i go to this donut shop i don't ever
go to starbucks or anything i go to the
donut shop and there's like
three guys in there and i'm like oh
there's a three [ __ ] guys in there oh
my god just get some cuff and go in
11 pictures later 6 40 in the morning
or now if you go uber each or grubhub
and i open the door
i take pictures with the with the
drivers
that's what happened when i see angela
the other night
she uh give me a shout out while we were
there
after the show she invited myself and my
family back
to her room so they came to people were
lined up they wanted to take pictures
and one of the guys one of the people
there told my son told my son
you want me to get more security over
here for you guys
and my son just said no my dad
he's not gonna want security just he'll
let him and i said it's okay
just quick ones okay that's it we got to
go there they're getting pissed off of
me
and let's go but it it does happen
you know when that happened when i went
to go see uh angela people just wanted
to take
what was she working at the comedy store
yeah they're umbrella
oh they improv yeah at the emperor so
it was a it's a new newer venue they had
an older one
they moved it up a block it's nice place
inside you know how long i've been on
the road i can tell somebody if a woman
wants to cool out by the way
she puts her hand on my back thank you
you know what i haven't had a lady or a
man i'm asking
yeah i need tails i have not had a lady
reach that far no seriously and if my
wife's around me she'll break her arm
no i know she would no because she's
she's beautiful and genuine but
but she's from the water you know that
when you have a lady from the hood
even wife or anything they know where to
hit you
that's my man you know she even jumped
in my case the other day because
on the show with uh i i forget who was
here
oh i said yeah my wife said you know
and we were talking about bill cosby
when we said yeah he's still guilty
liza was here yeah and i said my wife
said i don't care
i created controversy because i said
it's the law this is why
right i'm not saying anything this is
the law
and she just and i on the air i said my
wife said
sister mayor clarence said me puerta
madre whether the law or not this guy is
dirty
and she said you better let george know
i don't talk like that i wouldn't have
sent me porta
and i said a literary license i said it
you know it's okay i said sister mary
clarence
you know she said sister mike no way
what do you say
that's all it was you know uh it's a
touchy subject uh
bill cosby it's a touchy dude
it's quite against it yeah he's trying
to work and he's got nowhere to work i
don't think he'll
i don't think he's gonna find any place
to work
well you know with all these live
streaming uh
things maybe he could sort of start his
own
movement and get his you know almost i
mean because we've talked a lot in here
about how like uh the nightstalker would
have his sort of like contingent of fans
once he was
in prison and whatnot now bill's out he
can get like a patreon or some [ __ ] like
that there's ways
i got fans they wish they were having
his child still
they're sick people but you're going to
find the same thing i'm not going to
mention
which local national league baseball
team he plays for
and i'm not going to mention his name
but there's
he is on administrative leave right now
and nobody wants to touch him and he'll
probably never play
you mean the player yeah oh there's no
someone's going to pick him up he's too
good a player i i
don't think they're going to pick him
but according to him
there was nothing other than it was a
consensual play it was consensual he's
he says it there's no doubt they have
the the tapes you know they have the
text message it's consensual
but are you you know the the
the the gist is how are you going to
justify
that heavy a consensual if it was as
heavy as it was with her treatments and
her pictures
and then you know everybody knows you're
a cochino and they just don't want it
it's easier to say you were a thief then
but are you being are you being judged
in the court of public opinion
yes yes yes yes which which those are
the things that
when you read i remember i remember when
veragosa was running for mayor
and james han did that commercial
of him letting out drug dealers early on
furlough and there was somebody smoking
a pipe in a darkened room and it made it
look like so my grandmother says i'm not
going to vote for
viragosa because i heard that he smokes
you know crack
and i'm like from where and there's a
commercial but it
implied not even him but somebody that's
older i mean it's it's the imagery
yeah whoever did that knew exactly
exactly what they were doing so so i
think um
in the court of public opinion exactly
that's right now
when you stop and look at it it's taken
this long for the investigation
there there's no problem with dna why
haven't they filed why haven't they done
this so they're that
i don't know that anything will ever be
filed ever be adjudicated in court of
law
but in the court of public opinion he's
already doomed
okay so this will happen just like mr
cosby this is what happens when you have
a detective so those things have been
it's been going on for maybe a month and
a half now
longer than that about two months ago it
hasn't been charged okay
so you would say legally
if it's been going on that long and he
hasn't been charged there's nothing to
charge them with until proven
exactly i i can't imagine even after two
months
that they're waiting for lab results
those would have already been in
and he's already admitted yeah we had
sex so i don't know what kind of lab
results are waiting for
you know now it's a matter of being able
to prove
you for allegations and if you can't
prove it
well then he's gonna he's gonna get away
in the eyes of of the law and the
criminal justice system
but in the court of public opinion
he's already been but people make their
minds up sure and
you know kids and baseball
and and you're out has there been a
player that yassee al puig is not with
the team
no and he's not playing with anybody
right now he's not playing with anybody
nobody will pick him up
so i've i've gone out i still have lunch
with old friends of mine
from the department that have done time
in prison
that have gotten out and they got
convicted
for their thievery they were my friends
before they got caught
before they went in they did their time
they paid their punch
they're still my friends and i wouldn't
hesitate to go out to lunch
and i have does sister mary clarence
know you're still hanging out with him
oh yeah
yeah yeah she approves us all right you
just wouldn't leave them in your house
unattended if they're thieves because
well they they yeah they could come in
my house i don't know but i mean but i
mean if you
is that what they say so if you commit a
crime
and you go do your time and you come out
you served your yeah you should be
exonerated
you don't owe me that you know and
they've even told me you can ask me any
question you want to
i'll tell you everything that happened
well i said it's none of my business
you did it you paid your time
that's your personal business you're my
friend before you're still my friend so
i think
i think now if you look at that which is
true somebody said hey
i served my time but now because of
public opinion
you serve your time but it stays with
you the stigma of being
whoever you are stays with you now now
it's
it it's almost like a dirty word it's
sexual
involved so i'll go out with i'd stand
tall with my friends that
stole money and did their time but i'd
be would i be that willing to stand tall
with some guy that's
accused only accused of a sexual crime
and now i've got to explain continue to
explain that to everybody else
yeah so it's a tough one
but also you know like you know that
team will have to make a decision
uh and what they're liable for maybe
they didn't vet i don't think you can
vet that like they try to vet
things but you can't be if i were a
betting man i'd bet that he's not going
to play
for the for the team ever again i'll
never take the field with him again
and i don't think he'll take the team
he'll take the field with him alabama
had a team he'd be playing
that's for sure okay quick question dumb
question
that's true what are we talking about
here
uh for people myself included who don't
know the situation
there is a player on a local team that
has been accused
of felony battery essentially okay you
know because
he met a lady he said
she was into rough sex he has exchanged
text messages
where there is evidence that she was
into rough sex
but it was he might have choked her out
a little too much
seems to go beyond that perhaps exactly
where she is no longer saying yes and
there's still more violence going on
right and so he sort of turned into a
bit of a pariah amongst a team
so now everybody's just kind of stay
awake because they've all got wives
you know they've got girlfriends and hey
you're hanging around with that you have
kids that go
and jerseys and yeah so it's kind of a
tough situation
but what's motivating i mean
i guess that's the question like what
actually truly happened between these
two individuals
uh because if it was in fact consensual
what's motivating her to come out
and say these things was she looking for
a payout
is she aaron from downtown and
why did he not settle
i don't know sometimes when they're
looking for money they give you an
opportunity to to make an offer
before it became publicly yeah yeah and
if you say i got nothing to hide
or if you don't want to if he says be
extorted
you can say anything you want to through
hey we've got
text message right here saying you liked
it you liked
that right you're like and i understand
that that's me right there that's one of
my questions but as someone who's
who's who's trying to guide this young
man in in in the best
possible way there's just no coming out
of this situation
unscathed so it's it's interesting that
they actually let this
go as far as they as they did so it like
just came out this stuff just came to
light
no it came out about three weeks three
four weeks ago now we've been out
and they've just announced that they're
keeping him on administrative leave
longer
okay well i will say this i will say
that there's attorneys out there and
they're very expensive
but there's attorneys out there that
have saved
many people who are high-profile from
either charges or
from prison because
you pay them so much and they're so
connected they're very good at what they
do
that they ask you number one thing get
off your [ __ ] phone
get off your social media do not talk to
anybody
and let me do my work and they work
behind the scenes
but if you're gonna be tweeting things
and defending
it's not going to help you yeah he's
dead in the water once he starts doing
that
so yeah there was there was someone who
changed lanes and hit somebody in
oncoming traffic and and
killed a driver and that person never
was charged or never went to prison
because of the lawyer and the deal yeah
they can do that be friends with the d.a
and friends in high places i i just got
to believe
that he's going to have problems and i
right now just knowing the system like i
do i find it difficult to believe
that they're going to find him
criminally
wrong in anything you know there's not
going to be
it would surprise me if there were
charges filed against him
however this gentleman had just got
convicted yesterday
of the taking the guys up to his
apartment the big
uh who was that donator he was used to
give money to the
democratic uh party in west hollywood
he invited uh some guy up there they
gave him filled him up with meth
oh yes and now he's being charged with
charges you just got convicted of two
counts of murder yesterday because they
got high in his place
yes and then he was furnishing the drugs
for him
uh just got convicted yesterday i don't
know
what to say i don't yeah not um but
what is that i mean there's a los
angeles times article which i can read
it's ed buck
ed buck there you go ed buck convicted
in meth overdose deaths of gemma moore
and timothy dean
um long time f ed long time fixture of
west hollywood politics convicted
tuesday
charged he supplied the meth that killed
two men during party and play encounters
at his apartment
and so and that had gone on they'd
tried they'd investigated him since last
year you know trying to do it and they
finally just filed a
uh filed against him and didn't take
long for them to get him in and get him
out
it only took two days i think of
deliberation well i will i will say that
uh there are people who
uh come in contact with other people and
then those other people try to extort
money from someone for just being around
them
and with no allegation that is that is
real
other than an allegation they can make
that would be in the
in the court of public opinion and that
would taint that person
but they do it with no substance for
money
sure i agree with you there's people
that do that
and this this guy this guy and if you
defend yourself
you use the word taint and i think
that's what he was doing
in the team right there right there
brother entertain that
if you're in the chain area that's
you're that's almost like that's high
real estate
[Laughter]
he's just asking for trump all right
let's get out of here wrap it up
this this was great uh what else
anything to
plug uh angelo we can play any how long
did we talk
about anything but but i didn't hear any
guitar though that's the only thing
all right we'll keep that off uh
leave us voicemails we do uh answer
those eight one eight five three
eighteen forty three
one or nine right now it sounds like
let's answer one right now uh
you guys have headphones actually no we
don't have the setup ready i'd have to
have a
we talked about all kinds of stuff i
love this i'm just uh this will be one
to remember i'm honored this is it
i'm truly honored absolutely thank you
truly papa i love you yeah hey and this
is the show this is how it is that's how
you do it that's easy huh i want to
speak for jordan come back any time
come back any time i'd love to you
kidding me i'm just kidding
i don't care who's here i'm gonna be
who's that oh [ __ ]
this restaurant is really really really
good yeah please come from really great
you guys are
you guys right there on vineland and
ventura that's great
the three v's how can you go wrong with
v you know what it's really
vagina starts with v it can't be
[Laughter]
all right thank you all right papa thank
you